colombia cumple un mes de paro nacional
estamos en bogotá en la capital en una
de las salidas sur de la ciudad que los
manifestantes han renombrado como portal
resistencia parece que después de un mes
de protestas todavía está lejos la
salida al conflicto y es que el gobierno
y el comité nacional de paro todavía no
han iniciado negociaciones ya que las
posturas están muy lejanas el ejecutivo
de iván duque pide a los manifestantes
que levanten bloqueos como éste que
rigen en todo el país mientras que el
comité nacional de paro pide al gobierno
que desmilitariza ciudades como cali en
este contexto parece difícil saber cómo
va a evolucionar estas protestas que no
están siendo masivas en un punto
concreto sino que se reparten en muchos
tanto en bogotá como en colombia